yes friends Game of Thrones Season four
has come to an end this is going to be a
spoiler warning because I'm going to
talk about the season finale for season
four my recap some of the stuff has
happened in season four in general but
in the end we're going to talk about
this because it's the closure you know
me I don't always make Game of Thrones
videos but I will make a video of it
something really worth talking about
season finale of season 4 and I like
season 4 so let's talk about that but
this is the episode let's face it this
is the episode we've been waiting for
all season pretty much but definitely
the past two weeks this is the fate of
Tyrion Lannister I am pretty sure more
people tuned in this episode than the OJ
verdict this is big lie thought it was
gonna be last week then it was all the
wall it was a cool siege episode but I
was like what's happening with Tyrion
but more than that this episode broaden
the spectrum of Game of Thrones they
took it from being just Game of Thrones
to the song of Fire and Ice saga I tuned
into this episode all right what's gonna
happen to Tyrion and this episode
concentrated on the north so much that I
was like yeah that's really relevant
[ __ ] and hook Tyrion walks and
everything but it's all the north right
now you feel like the magical going-ons
in the north is a pretty important thing
straight-up though that bran stark
campaign and his whole crew and what
they have to do you know stick together
and there's magic and their skeletons
coming after it I was like this reminds
me of something out of Fire Emblem
that's it right down to the perma deaths
when a fake looking skeleton hand stabs
you in the stomach and you died now that
dude who reminds me a link from Legend
of Zelda is no longer in the show I
guess the fate of Tyrion Lannister right
to be clear that episode with the Viper
versus the mountain yeah that was cool
sure the mountain has that dude on his
back is like our larders and he crushes
and you see chef boyardee just and
everyone out there watching who hadn't
read the books is like Tyrion Lannister
is [ __ ] so you guys were wondering why I
didn't do a video on that and that's
just because I knew Tyrion would not die
now to be clear I haven't read the books
and no one who has read the books told
me Tyrion wasn't gonna die I knew Tyrion
wasn't gonna die and that's just kind of
how my brain works that's why I don't
talk Game of Thrones a lot except for a
certain select amount of people because
someone out there will say one thing
that makes me go weight of that bout
[ __ ] that means this example someone was
talking with me about Game of Thrones
and I was talking about how awesome
Tyrion is and they were like oh yeah
george RR martin said Tyrians his
favorite character i was like [ __ ]
tyrion libs he's going to live it's
gonna be the most unbelievable thing to
happen in Game of Thrones because if it
were anyone else on trial that wasn't
the author's favorite character that
dude would be dead now but not so after
you guys Hey
crushin everyone around me was freaking
out everyone online was freaking out I
was like no big deal it's just a guy who
got his head crushed on Game of Thrones
this happens on Game of Thrones a lot of
people died to me it was never the fate
of Tyrion Lannister being sealed is that
a bummer yes but again that's why I
don't talk Game of Thrones with a lot of
people there's actually another spoiler
out there that I now know to be fair
people who have read all the books don't
actually know the answer to it someone
said one thing there's a conversation
that george RR martin had with somebody
of course it was for some odd reason
people need to fill me in on what the
author talks about don't do that [ __ ]
and I was like wait that may that means
this and again no one out there really
has the answer except George RR martin
and a couple of the people i imagine but
one of my friends who has read the book
was like [ __ ] i think you actually
spoiled a part of the book for me
because i you are right the outcome that
you were that is what that means
that's right someone who has never read
the books who has only seen the show has
ruined an aspect to Game of Thrones or
at least the Song of Fire and Ice books
for someone who has read all the books
it's not easy being a genius but if the
burden i bear is the bag of bricks i
carry for the people to be clear I'm not
saying Tyrion is invincible and above
death he can certainly die I just didn't
think george RR martin would have tyrion
go out the way season four looked like
it was gonna have him go out if tyrion
actually did kill Joffrey I feel like
yeah sure he could die but since he
didn't I just don't think george RR
martin was gonna let tyrion take the
fall for a murder he didn't actually
commit and that would be that and it's
his favorite character and yeah and
george RR martin maybe a literary serial
killer but he still has his favorite
character and he's not gonna have him go
out like that he's still human believe
it or not it was great how tyrion got
away with it i did not know she was
gonna be in Tywin's bed right when i saw
that i was like people are going to die
and now tyrion has 99 problems but she
ate one she's cheese toast now who
wouldn't choke her out screw that noise
point the finger at him and that trial
that reminded me of the Chrono Trigger
trial she was like he ate the meat after
fighting gateau and Tywin convinced her
to do it all consensually from the waist
down
no yeah waster so now she's toast he
takes his crossbow he finds Tywin taking
his [ __ ] yeah Tywin is all watching
YouTube videos and tweeting on the
toilet and Tyrians like now choose him a
couple times of the crossbow just pow
pow you're like good job Tyrion for you
yeah you may have found out that chick
you loved was banging your dad and then
your dad's always been a dick
all
these bad things happen but you know
what in the end you got yours I guess
technically the phrase would be Tywin
got his point is I love Tywin he was a
great character I didn't expect him to
die and now he's dead time is truly the
great equalizer in Westeros Cersei
Lannister children are all technically
Lannister inbred children but legally
they are Baratheon so they're not going
to carry on the Lannister name Jaime
Lannister is not going to carry on the
Lannister name can't marry you no he
swore all that [ __ ] off Tyrion Lannister
might something tells me he's not going
to go under the Lannister name since
he's sentenced to die if he does still
go under Tyrion Lannister is gonna be
someplace kind of far away probably as
Cersei Lannister is not gonna marry sir
Lawrence yeah bye Tyrion killing Tywin
ultimately he did do Cersei is solid
ultimately no one's gonna carry on the
Lannister name past this current
generation so yeah there was no red
wedding for the Lannisters but
ultimately it's the same effect as the
rains of castamere no one will remember
their name eventually and it'll all just
be gone that's right time itself is the
Swift hand of stark justice that or a
crossbow to the chest well someone's
taking a [ __ ] that works if for nothing
else this season left off with me going
what is what's next season really feels
like this transition you know Arya is
going to the volumn Agulhas people and
she's gonna find like the faceless dude
again hopefully I realize I did it's bad
I use one of the coolest characters ever
in the show for all we know the hounds
dead if the Hound lives that will be the
second most unbelievable thing that has
happened now in Game of Thrones yeah
that includes skeletons rising from the
dead shed Tyrion is going and then
various he hears the bells and gets back
on the ship I don't know if Varys got
back on the ship to make sure Tyrion got
to his destination safely or if he was
like Heather is still a person or two
who knows that I got Tyrion out of there
so I'm gonna leave in either case he's
gone with Tyrion to wherever which makes
me go is it going to be as interesting
Tyrion is so good in King's Landing that
him anywhere else well I don't know if
it'll be as interesting who knows maybe
he'll meet up with khaleesies ex-friends
on the real I can understand his take
Gracie's dragons and go to King's
Landing and take it for herself and
suckle on some teach I also like this
season because of khaleesies campaign
police's campaign to be clear is like
the biggest dick tease ever we just want
to see dragons wreck [ __ ] and wreck [ __ ]
more than sheep and and you know kids
that apparently fall from the sky cuz
one eats them in burn them we want to
see Khaleesi take King's Landing that
would be awesome
and then she's over there to hanging out
with her crew and stuff but up until now
every
was kind of been like oh cool easy we'll
follow you and she's a fan favorite you
know she's this really strong female
character at the end of season three
everyone's hoisting her on her back
hands up is this big circle everyone's
like oh you're she Jesus you're awesome
and I'm like we get it but it's almost
nauseating at this point it's too easy
for her it's like she's too perfect of a
person give her some adversity more than
little weird warlocks in a place called
Qarth I mean real political [ __ ] and
this one it was it was like oh yeah
Khaleesi wanted to do all that justice
so he just massed slaughtered all those
masters yeah my dad was one of them he
was a good guy you're a dick cuz she's
running to more of that I like that [ __ ]
cuz I'm like yeah it's tough isn't it
kiddo in the end it's not going to
matter cuz it looks like shits coming
from the north and I'm actually more
interested in the [ __ ] in the north and
I've ever been in the history of Game of
Thrones Thank You season finale for
doing that I love what that elder elf
guy in the north told brandy said
something along the lines of you will
never walk but you will fly bran can
control animals dragons are in the world
dragons are animals
I think Brad's gonna control the dragon
all we know is Tyrion lives another day
and that's never been I just now hope
Tyrians campaign as it is from here on
is still as interesting nothing's worse
than when a character lives and he's
useless now especially when he's such a
cool character like Tyrion Lannister I
so the Game of Thrones season finale for
season four and season four in general
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you